so welcome to our
soda cl workshop
um
i'm
tom i'm the co-founder and cto of soda
i've built some open source communities
in the past mostly like in workflow
engines in the java space
and
now at soda
i actually am the one driving like it
was a team effort of course and we build
upon some experiences but i was the main
driver behind soda cl language which is
the
main content of this workshop which is
giving you an idea about this new
language
that
that you can use for data reliability
and we're going to use that in practice
but i'm also going to sketch first 15
minutes
more the context of
how this fits into a whole data team
like what does it mean for the engineers
what does the language do and how does
this fit when people start to
collaborate around data reliability
okay so
soda does data quality and observability
i'm gonna
give you like a better clearer picture
of what it exactly means but i think if
you are in a data team and you have data
in production then you all know that you
will have broken data once in a while
and sometimes these damages
are relatively clear
like for instance if you calculate hotel
room prices on a daily basis and
the data gets broken or not updated
you're calculating the wrong prices with
direct impact on your revenue so for the
business that's quite a
catastrophe and that's clear there's
also a lot of hidden damages like
internal friction like if some data goes
bad and you need like with five team
members to figure out what's going on
and by the time you figured it out and
fixing all that that says a lot of
internal friction
and there's of course loss of reputation
as well
like either personally or for the
company if the data goes bad so that's
those damages you need to protect
yourself against and
that's where soda comes in
um if you want to tackle this problem so
soda itself handles the the whole life
cycle of finding and resolving data
issues at scale means like
as a business process so it's something
that happens frequently so you need to
be prepared when it happens so that you
can actually spot them
and to resolve them uh systematically
that's uh that's what we do but a simple
health dashboard is not sufficient like
um the starting point is often that look
we connected the data you get like a
help desk dashboard
which is fully automatic there's also
something that we cover but that's not
good enough because
what you need to do is you need to make
sure that everyone can collaborate to
build up a picture of what good data
looks like and that that actually gets
checked as well
and that requires
significant collaboration between people
and that's our main focus
of the the product
so this gives an overview of what soda
can do for you what use cases we handle
so we can test data as it lands
so in your warehouse
right after it lands in your data
pipeline as an engineer you can use our
cli our library that we're going to show
in a minute
to test your data as it comes in
then after your transformations you also
want to check as an engineer
quickly like what are is is the
transformation and is the prepared data
the refined data as we wanted
that's also an engineering use case
and then the third engineering use case
is the automated health dashboards which
are in the bucket of data observability
and automated monitoring
and in the next two sections i'm going
to elaborate a bit further down on
agreements agreements come from the
notion of
like if you know data mesh that kind of
hints at data products and in data
products it has to be like really clear
what are you handing over you need to
describe very well the the data that
you're handing over and with that comes
like executable uh service level
objectives that's that's what you can
see as an agreement so we're gonna build
these check files that
exec execute exactly that
and then the
two last parts
analyzing your alerts when they get
raised when you get notifications then
you need to analyze like what exactly
happened and you have a incident
workflow when you once you identify the
root cause
then you need to um
collaborate with people to get the thing
fixed and that's uh that's all in scope
for soda
so that gives you a bit of
yeah and
all of these together
this is something that you need to be as
i mentioned before you need to be
prepared for that this is gonna happen a
lot
so as a
chief data officer or head of analytics
the value is that sort of helps you
drive this business process that you
don't have to do firefighting every time
something happens no everyone knows like
this is how we find issues this is what
we need to do to actually raise the
issues
um to create visibility and then
we have a good process to handle that so
that everyone knows what to do
okay now on to
that's the context
of soda itself now onto soda cl we have
been starting
some first
versions with soda sql we launched that
last year in open source so the sql is
the the first language which really took
yaml and sql as the primary targets
which we kind of
were inspired by by dbt because they
also have this focus and that enabled
that focus enabled them as well to
address
more use cases towards the analyst so
analysts could actually produce
dbt transformations and that's what we
saw as well with soda sql so we make it
a lot simpler than just with coding to
create data reliability checks
into your pipelines
and so after the learnings we did for
the last year
we
spotted a few errors that triggered us
to completely revisit the language and
that's what we are presenting here today
so we have just released today this in
beta stage and for public
for public use so you can now start the
using this and that's you'll be the
first to be guided through the the whole
installation and getting it uh
running on your machine
um so sort of
cl itself
is important because
like the fact that there's a language
for this is important because otherwise
there's different
roles and backgrounds for all the people
that work with data some are really
technical programmers some can be a bit
dangerous with sql
and there's like a whole range in
between
now
what this single language offers is that
you can
so the single language enables that all
of these people use the same language
rather than creating island
if you don't have this language then
every all the work comes down to the
engineer basically
and that creates a bottleneck that's the
one we are trying to remove
and here you can see that
there's two values that we offer one is
for the engineers we make it
very easy first of all the language is
easy to write and read
but more important it's the deployment
like it fits within the workflows of the
engineers they want their files in their
git repository they want to run them
inside of their pipelines
which is like a completely different
deployment model and they want open
source as well so that's different from
the value that
the analysts want they want like for
instance in a cloud tool they want to
mess around with the language and they
would just want to press save or test in
a browser rather than
doing this in in their own git and
programming environment
and that's what
what we offer we have one language that
works in these two environments
and of course it's open source
we have an open core model so that's why
we came to the name of
soda core because that is the name of
the project that can execute these soda
cl files so soda cl is the language name
so the core is the project
and it's open source which means like
you can completely like there's no
it's not crippleware which often
is the case for us we can all everything
that's for the engineer to embed your
checks in your pipelines that's all uh
included and it's fully functional
without any requirement for soda cloud
of course if you connect it if you
connect soda core to soda cloud then you
will see that this gets a lot more
richer because then you can make use of
the metric store that is in soda cloud
which makes it really powerful because
then all your checks can start to use
the history as well
i think that's about it
and now i'll walk you through
the
three main
deployment and usage styles of soda cl
it's quite important because often this
is implicit with other tools that that
is kind of like one style
and we're quite proud that we're able to
cover these multiple styles of
deployment so that because we realize
that engineers want to consume this and
want to work with checks and data
reliability in a different way than the
analysts first style is you have a this
represents a
data pipeline or a dag an airflow deck
of some sorts
where and then the where do you want to
run your soda checks that's like at the
very beginning to check your inputs
once the data is landed for instance you
first want to check like did the input
data is that like
is that valid or is that like are there
any problems there then you apply your
transformations and afterwards you want
to do some checks
on the results as well to see if that if
those make sense um so those are the two
places in your pipeline where you want
to
where you want to do some soda checks
and this is the style where you
typically embed it with the cli or with
the python library embedded into your
pipeline
now agreements is and the previous one
was kind of like a
known pattern
i think this one is quite exciting as
well because
so the cl can also be used
in the context of agreements now what
does that mean you see the files
over there that's where a lot of people
like analysts as well can start writing
sort of cl checks
um in these files which then get picked
up automatically for instance on a daily
basis and they get executed that's what
you see in the scan so scan for us is a
notion where a number of sort of cl
files gets
are being read
all the checks are being
parsed and then you're going to go to
the data to evaluate if all the checks
are okay or if they fail if they pause
or fail
so that's an that's a notion of the scan
now the agreements are as i mentioned
before the executable service level uh
objectives
they say like
if you produce your data it means like
you can write in a sort of cl file like
this is what we guarantee in terms of
freshness in terms of completeness
or in terms of validity all of those
things can be documented in such a file
and then it becomes an agreement you say
like i publish my data and together with
that i publish my contract or my
agreement
that states this the same way goes for
the for the consumer so what i just
explained was for data producers
but the data consumers they have their
reports or machine learning models
that use the data
and they have certain dependencies they
require that this column is available or
that
it has to be certain data type or
like all the checks that we're going to
explore
everything that you depend on
when you're building a data product
that's what you can also express in an
agreement so when all these agreements
can now just be pushed to it as files in
a central repository somewhere
and the repository can be git but it can
also be just on our cloud
and then they get executed and this
simplifies the whole thing of getting a
check into production
because now you don't need to write code
and deploy code into production no just
simply storing a file somewhere will
actually add new checks
to your data
so that's a style two style three is the
automated and
monitoring and observability style that
means like
which is similar as the one before
in the sense that the only difference is
that
for this one you don't need people to
write the files because uh soda scan is
going to just on a daily basis look at
your data and try to find automatically
like what are the things you want to be
notified about
and this of course gives you like a good
base layer of coverage
but it doesn't give you like the
expressiveness or the preciseness that
often needed in these agreements
and you can see this also as uh similar
to
infrastructure as code because
what you now have is a system that's
automated
but the way that it's set up like which
tables should be checked for instance
like you might only want to do all the
automated stuff on the subset of tables
and how far you want to go into the
automation
all those configurations are now in
files so that you can version control
them and that's a similar as
infrastructure as code
and here you can see like the last
part of this introduction
you can see
where we're heading at with our soda
cloud
so the cloud will be an editor and like
an authoring environment for soda cl
files
where you can start editing that where
of course the syntax highlighting and
there's some assistance there help you
build checks
but you can also test them this is
technologically like not
so easy because of course we need to
make sure that your data stays where it
is
and we need to
run your checks on that data so there we
have some some significant
infrastructure in place to make sure
that we can offer this as a fully
managed service and where you can test
and alter your checks
um okay so i'll walk you now through
some of the examples and then we can
start
and get going with the installing
everything
and
getting a taste for yourself
so some of the examples um are like um
cross checks uh this gives you already a
flavor of how the language looks like in
this case you're running a
check on the customers table and you
want to check like if the row count here
is the same as
in another table that
that it's used as the source data
one of the reason that i actually took
this is it also shows one of the unique
capabilities that we have because we can
do this check not only in the same
warehouse or in the same
data store but also across data stores
so we can do this validation on multiple
data stores
here's like freshness and schema checks
are included
all within like a very compact language
easy to read so it's
tailored so that you can not only easily
write the language but also reading so
we we foresee that on so like cloud a
lot more people will actually read these
checks it's going to be documentation
with your language with your
data that you produce
as well
so just to give you like a
a flavor and here you can see like for
automation and observability you can
figure like which are the tables that
are included and what kind of anomalies
we should go for
um that can be configured as
well uh let's check all right so i think
uh now is a good time to switch to the
workshop where
it's uh it's up to you ah wait and i
think i got the
ordering of my slides not completely
right because now is the time where
this link if you start there will guide
you through i'm going to show that in a
minute we'll guide you through
a github repository
and that readme has the full
instructions to go through a full
exercise
of running some scans and looking at the
checks and where you can start play with
the checks as well
we have a fully worked out example there
so that you don't have to start from
scratch but that you can just
get it running and i'll be going through
with you together like step by step on
the installation process and we'll be
walking around if there's any questions
in the meantime
so i'll do this to
i'll walk through the
through the repository
let's see how can i get this
think
let's see
maybe it's easier if i now go into
emitter mode
that's a good point
anyone not yet having docker on their
system
wow
awesome
let me share this
okay
so this is the workshop repository and
it will there's two things you need to
check like do you have docker
then you still can get it installed
docker is needed for i'll just walk
through all the different steps first so
that you have a bit of context and then
you can get going or you can just
already start if you want but i'll walk
you through it
you need like python and docker to get
started there's a slack channel and a
slack community that we have which is
really valuable people help each other
out with questions and answers as you go
and there's like a dedicated channel now
for which like if there's a
so that people are there to to help out
if or we can walk around as well if you
raise your hand then we'll see how we
can get it fixed but definitely it's a
good thing good practice to just already
register
there's documentation for soda core and
soda cl
the links can be found there
which you might want
to review and then the demodap data
docker container
that is the
docker and that
container is actually
used to just give you a set of tables in
a database to work with that's the
example of data so if you run and start
this docker container
you will have
a postgres that comes up and it has the
demo data
i think five tables in it so that you
can run your examples on that
that is the docker container
instructions then
there's this repository
you
you want to get the files of this
repository locally we've seen that like
the clone will not work in this network
and so you will have to
do like the download zip option here to
get the files going
on your machine
then the next step is to install the
solar
oh how
oh wow
yeah but you might have a different
network and you're not using
okay
cool
and you must have good privileges here
on the network right
all right
so then installing the cli
um and of course in in practice we see
that most
people and companies start using the api
after a while to embed it into their
pipelines
but like to get started for and to learn
about it and see the possibilities then
the cli is most convenient of course
so this
includes the instruction on how to
create a virtual environment in python
on your machine and how to install soda
so
soda postgres will install the core
package soda core and the extension
module for postgres we have like an
extension module for all the different
databases and warehouses
and let's see ah right and the next step
after you've done that is registering a
soda cloud account and as i mentioned
this is like if you're using soda that's
optional but of course we want to show
you now in this workshop the extra value
that you get from connecting to soda
cloud
and then finally we come to the
running the check files there is three
example check files that you can start
from
and
you can then
run these or like review them in your
editor
review the files and run the scan and
you will see the report that comes out
of it on the console
and if you run them a couple of times
that's something i actually didn't
include in the instructions if you run
them a couple of times that makes the
soda cloud
browsing more interesting because then
you will see
your history over time as a chart rather
than as a single dot if you just run it
once
every scan
and this is the part where like we put
loads of effort into making this a great
language
and
i'm preparing this presentation so we
want to ask you one small favor in
return
it's already great that you're here but
if you could give you us your feedback
that would be very appreciated
and you can do that either publicly in
the data council
channel
or any channel that you find is good but
if you prefer to do it privately then
just email it to workshop
dot io that's as you want
and this is like if you want to conf if
you want to look at the data in the
docker container then this shows a
little bit uh instructions for it
okay so that's a in a nutshell
um
i don't know yet how we're going to take
it but i guess like
um
you
probably is good at you just try to see
how far you can go like if you take the
next step it's okay and every couple of
minutes i will do it as well here show
you
how it's done